a CBS News investigation has learned
Ford may be closer to a major recall
that could affect police departments
across the country for months CBS News
has been tracking possible carbon
monoxide leaks inside Ford Explorers
police departments around the u.s. say
fumes are seeping into the SUVs and
making officers sick federal safety
regulators have logged thousands of
complaints 1.3 million explorers are
under federal investigation the problem
gained national attention after we
showed you this 2015 video of a
California police Explorer slamming into
a tree the officer behind the wheel had
passed out he blamed a carbon monoxide
leak in Auburn Massachusetts today Ford
engineers are inspecting ten Explorer
police cruisers for a second full day
the chief says an officer passed out and
rear-ended another car he is among six
Auburn police officers recently treated
for carbon monoxide exposure Kris Van
Cleave is in Montgomery County Maryland
where crews are inspecting all 108 of
the county's Explorers Chris good
morning good morning and what they're
finding in explorer after Explorer are
cracks in the exhaust manifolds now
that's a part that takes exhaust away
from the engine and it's not just here
in Montgomery County it's police
departments across the country and
that's what has Ford now actively
considering a recall of its best-selling
Ford Explorer police interceptors we
instantly saw the danger that our
mechanics in Montgomery County Maryland
are finding cracked manifolds and their
Ford Explorers so often we believe this
is a manufacturer's defect that David
dies who oversees fleet maintenance for
the county believes the problem could be
affecting up to 80 percent of the fleet
most are police cruisers the exhaust
manifold collects gases from an engine
cylinders a crack could release carbon
monoxide into the engine bay and through
the vents of a vehicles cabin if you're
running your air conditioning or your
vent system that's the air that's coming
through the engine compartment so you
are sucking carbon monoxide into the
cabin if if you have that kind of a leak
while Ford engineers are not convinced
the cracked manifolds are causing the
exhaust complaints the cracks are common
enough to prompt Ford to actively
consider up attend
costly recall there are an estimated
135,000 Explorer police cruisers on the
road today police departments in more
than a dozen states have raised concerns
about possible carbon monoxide leaks
Ford has declined multiple requests for
an interview but did release this video
statement there is nothing that we take
more seriously than providing you with
the safest most reliable vehicles to
support your life-saving work in
February we were first to show you this
frightening 2015 crash in California the
police officer driving passed out he
believes it was carbon monoxide and is
now suing Ford following more than 2700
complaints federal regulators last week
expanded their investigation to cover
model years 2011 to 2017 saying
preliminary testing suggests Co levels
may be elevated in certain driving
scenarios they live in these cruisers
for a you know eight hours at a time it
may be longer in Auburn Massachusetts a
third of the town's cruisers are out of
service
the local police chiefs Association
tells CBS News at least 15 police
agencies in that state alone have
sidelined Ford Explorers and are
awaiting a solution from Ford adding the
concern among Massachusetts police
chiefs is exceptionally high it was just
a week ago Austin Police pulled four
hundred plus explorers out of service
Galveston Texas police have taken their
explorers out of service until they can
be inspected departments across the
country are now rushing to inspect their
vehicles and add carbon monoxide
detectors Ford says it is working with
police departments and no final decision
has been made on a recall flat Chris
thanks